if you see the level
coming down really really very low i
wanted to keep going down to a baseline
that's so low
that there's virtually no threat if you
combine
getting most of the people in the
country vaccinated with getting the
level of
virus in the community very very low
then i believe you're going to be able
to say you know for the most part we
don't necessarily have to wear mass
dr faucio there laying out the case for
continued mask wearing into
2022 even as the vaccination rollout
accelerates in the u.s and with the
first real-world evidence of the
vaccine's impact coming out of israel
will be returned to normal sooner than
the biden administration is predicting
joining us now fox news contributor and
author of the book covid the politics of
fear and the power of science dr mark
siegel let's just put this on the board
here for people to see
that the pfizer efficacy data in israel
is very impressive 98.9 percent
effective at preventing death
89.4 effective in preventing infection
and 78 doses administered per 100 people
um do we have to really think about
wearing mass into
2022 doctor well let's put it this way
dana we need a simple message that we
can all go by and here's what it is
i think that dr fauci who i respect a
lot is being
too pessimistic provided we follow the
other part of his message which is get
vaccinated
we have less than a 50 percent we have a
problem with about 40 to 50 percent of
americans that are still not saying
they're going to get vaccinated
so i say to the people out there get the
vaccine then we'll talk about taking off
the mask that's how simple it is
i don't think it's going to be 2022
provided we can get this country
vaccinated and the data you just showed
proves it the pfizer data out of israel
are is incredibly impressive and new
data looks like
it cuts down on transmissibility which
is the key that's why i'm talking about
protect everybody around you already
don't just protect yourself you won't
get hospitalized the chances are you
won't get sick the chances are you won't
even get the infection
very high percentages dana just show on
top of that very little
chance you're going to transmit it to
others you want to take that mask off
take the vaccine doctor the decrease in
cases
and deaths and hospitalizations over the
past
well i guess going back to early january
are extraordinary
we're down 77 percent since the high
right around the first of the year and
then there's this news too
top countries the covet vaccine doses
administered
we ranked number four israel one uae 2
united kingdom 3 us4 are we doing a lot
better job than the media is telling us
yes because of bill all the political
backbiting you know the administration
doesn't want to give
any credit to the previous
administration they want to say that
nothing was done properly when meanwhile
we had this
enormous rollout in a vaccine that was
put together in nine months
the states are fighting each other new
york state had to put another
an extra layer of surveillance in on the
vaccine now we're finally finding
information out that's going to really
help bill we're finding out that the
fisa vaccine can probably be stored
in a regular freezer that's going to
mean a bigger rollout we're getting more
people on the ground to administer these
vaccines we're getting more vaccine
centers
we're almost up to 2 million doses a day
now
but we were up to 1 million at the time
that there was a changing of the guard
so i
that's why i think we're doing a pretty
good job with vaccine a lot of things
bill
are making us move in the right
direction we're not gathering as much
we're wearing masks we're starting to
get vaccinated the key thing is though
that we also have a lot of immunity
built up in the in the
in the country probably and again this
is not provable
it's just we don't know this for sure
but there's certainly been a lot more
cases
of covet 19 out there than we know about
people that had symptoms that didn't get
tested
people that that didn't have symptoms
that guided asymptomatically that didn't
get tested
people that might have antibodies people
that might have t-cell immunity they
don't know about
that's a significant number as well all
of this is going towards slowing it down
and it's hard to your point it's hard to
measure that
um but it looks like things are headed
in the right direction if you look at
these charts i know bill
follows the new york times that bar
chart keeps going down
and in the meantime we've got this huge
covert relief bill that is going through
the house of representatives dr siegel
thank you